okay so House of the Dragon sets up some
major things for the prince who has
promised prophecy which would end up
coming to fruition in Game of Thrones
episode 7 has a major moment in it in
which Alison Katrina's hand and this
could all tie everything together to
bring things full circle with Game of
Thrones as we've been saying every week
it was thought that Jon Snow would be
the one to fulfill the prophecy but in
the end it turned out to be Arya whether
there is a way can all still come
together and make sense without Jon Snow
actually having to carry it out there's
a number of ways they're connected and
if you had issues with the way the
prophecy played out in the long night
then hopefully this at least saved some
of season 8 for you hopefully now as you
can guess throughout this video we're
going to be breaking it all down and if
you enjoy it we'd massively appreciate
the thumbs up also don't forget to
subscribe for videos on the show every
week and a big breakdown for the
episodes right after they release but
out of the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video
firstly I have to give a huge shout out
to our editor Matt who first notices
tine when we were putting on episode 7
video out together since then we've been
going over everything to talk about how
the blood being on the blade stops
things from contradicting for the first
part of the video I want to talk about
what the prophecy is so you can kind of
get a brief understanding of that before
we delve into how the blade connects to
it in case you don't know the prince who
has promised prophecy is what the Lord
of Light religion is based around and it
was brought to the Forefront by egg on
the Conqueror he had a dream that showed
a great force coming from the North and
the only way to stop this was through
his bloodline being in charge though the
word Prince is often interpreted as
being about a man it is important to
bear in mind that the term comes from
hypolarian in this language the word
Prince is actually gender neutral and
therefore there's been a number of
candidates that could fit the role many
thought that it was Stannis Baratheon
but this then changes Jon Snow Danny and
even Arya the prophecy states that the
figure will be born amid salt and smoke
and using a sword named lightbringer
they'll combat the impending Darkness
the prince is also supposed to be a
Reincarnation of Azor ahai a legend
every Warrior that be it Darkness during
the long night thousands of years ago
aegon had a dream that this figure would
return one day and he believed that it
would come from its bloodline he said
that this would be the Song of Ice and
Fire and this phrase was carved into the
Valerian dagger similar to the hidden
message on the One Ring this could only
be displayed with fire and it relayed
all of Akon's message The Song of Ice
and Fire is of course the name of the
book series Game of Thrones was adapted
into and it's something that viserys and
Sam Walter reference the prophecy has
been secretly passed from King to King
and King to Queen to make sure that
those who inherit the throne will know
to pass on the message due to what
happens in the books it's unlikely that
raniera will ever pass this on to
someone who sits on the throne but she
could possibly relate to her children
and so on and so forth however as we
never hear of it in Game of Thrones I'm
guessing that it got lost a time though
it's also possible that DND had no idea
what they were doing so they never set
it up now all of this could be the show
just trying to fix the ending of Game of
Thrones but I can't say that I'll be mad
if they may managed to pull this off now
for the next part of the video I want to
talk about the timeline of the dagger
and where it eventually ends up this is
a rough timeline of it and where it
travels through this story in Game of
Thrones so that we can talk about more
of our theories and where it's going to
end up in the end should it really call
this video prophecy time prophecy time
but uh we'll we'll avoid all that
because I know you guys hate it now in
Game of Thrones the dagger ends are
being carried by the Assassin who
attempts to kill Brandon Winterfell
after his fall from the tower thus it
definitely falls out of Targaryen hands
and we're likely gonna see what happens
to it as we get further into house of
the Dragon now after this attack fails
the dagger is then shown as several
characters who all conclude that it has
to belong to someone wealthy due to it
being made out of valerian steel after
taking it with her to King's Landing
Catelyn discovers that it belonged to
Littlefinger who apparently lost it in a
better Tyrion he denies this it says
it's all fabricated and afterwards Ned
keeps it with him Littlefinger then ends
up taking it after he betrays Ned and he
keeps it with him all the way up to
season seven in the end he gives it a
brand who then passes it on to Aria
because he can't fight in a cruel twist
of fate Arya ends up using it on
Littlefinger when he gets executed for
committing treason they even theorize
that Littlefinger actually owned it all
along because of tyrion's denial this
would mean that he was the one who sent
the Assassin to bran and he may have
gave it to him as a way to try and broke
a piece from this point onwards Arya
keeps a dagger herself and she ends up
carrying it across the sea at the end of
season 8. so it's still out there which
we'll talk more about later on in the
video now the saying carved into it also
has a strong connection to aegon's blood
which I think is what the hand slice is
playing upon when this happens we get a
strong focus on it dripping from
raniera's hand and this is symbolic for
a number of reasons not only is it
Alison drawing First Blood between the
pair but the blood itself is now also on
the blade a Jon Snow can trace his
lineage all the way back to an Era
making him tie directly to the prince
who was promised the blade now carries
the bloodline on it too so no matter
what happens it can help to defeat the
night king without necessarily having to
be in his hand the prophecy also doesn't
specifically state that a Targaryen
needs to be on the throne either and
therefore it's still possible that it
becomes complete in Game of Thrones now
another interesting aspect tying into
the bloodline is that Daenerys is also a
descendant of aegon therefore the prince
who has promised prophecy could be
talking about multiple people and this
is why many are confused over whether
it's Danny or John Danny was born
amongst seeing salt and therefore she
might be fulfilling part of it on the
other side of it Jon could end up
filling the lightbring apart and thus
the term Prince being interchangeable
gender-wise could also mean that it's
still technically true so in order for
it to all come together we have the
prophecy that states either a male or
female from aegon's bloodline will come
forth and destroy the darkness that will
come from the north this evil will be
defeated using the blade which I ends up
doing who knows she might even be
revealed as being a Targaryen at some
point because their family tree is
probably dying for a couple of extra
branches that aren't connected to it I
doubt it but that's something to bear in
mind as we start heading towards the
next part of the video now it is also
possible that this will be covered more
in the upcoming Jon Snow series that's
rumored to be in development though Kit
Harington has said that he knows nothing
about it George RR Martin has openly
talked about it at several points and it
will likely be something that fills the
gap between the two years it takes to
make House of the Dragon I can't see it
getting to the point where they look for
a big bad in that series and they may
even end up pulling the night King back
into it once more this could lead to Jon
facing up against him one final time and
he may then stab the villain with the
blade which would lead to it all being
fulfilled I don't know though guys
should be dead but yeah this spin-off
series will be interesting to see as we
don't really have anything in the box
that hints towards where things could be
going with it being a spin-off series
I'm guessing that it will have cameos in
it too which will probably feature some
returning characters this could end up
leading into the return of Arya who may
end up giving the dagger back to Jon as
she was the one last seen with it if
this is the case then she could also be
pulled into fighting the night King once
more seeing as she was the person who
defeated him in the first place there's
lots of different ways to take it and
I'm sure we'll learn it more and more as
we get into the future episodes and
seasons of House of the Dragon either
way I loved hear your thoughts on the
theories how it connects to an Era being
cut and generally what you think will
happen next for it to pass from House of
dragon into Game of Thrones comment
below and let me know and just to let
you know we're running competition right
now and giving away three copies of
dollar and thunder on the 15th of
October all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the theories if you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on the screen right now save that to
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch them make sure you check out our
breakdown of the episode 8 trailer which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the full thing from top to
bottom so definitely head over there
right after this without the way thanks
for singing through the video I've been
poured I'll see you in the next one take
care peace